Welcome back everyone there were some big
announcements about Marvel's Avengers 6
Secret Wars movie and how they're wrapping up
the Multiverse storyline with a bunch of Easter
eggs and references to even the oldest pre-mcu
movies that will actually weirdly enough pay
off references and deleted scenes in things
that they tried to do in those earlier movies
but just couldn't for whatever reason and they're
bringing back a big Legacy Marvel movie director
to actually make the movie I know there's tons
of questions about Marvel's splitting Secret
Wars into two movies now I'll address that
too because that would mean they'd release
three Avengers movies in three years back to back
which is unprecedented that'd be like them just
Wheeling out dump trucks of money from the movie
theaters if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos speaking
of Multiverse Spider-Man across the spider versus
also coming out this week there's lots of rumors
about how they're tying that into the secret Wars
plot down the road with the second part in
beyond the spiderverse I've got a bunch of
videos for that planned and we're giving away
movie tickets to random people in the comments
I'll name winners during this video and thank
you to raid Shadow Legends for sponsoring this
week's giveaway raid is one of the biggest mobile
games in the world that's totally free to play and
they just premiered a limited series called raid
call The Arbiter which is available free inside
the raid Shadow Legends game new episodes are
released inside the game every Thursday at 10
A.M eastern time the finale scheduled for July
20th and all you have to do to watch is just log
into the game you don't have to sign up for like
the brilliant streaming service which is kind of
nice the series gets into the wider lore of the
game so if you're a big fan of that it actually
goes pretty deep on it they're also celebrating
the release of the series by adding a ton of extra
lore to the character bios and giving you a chance
to get our attack one of the characters from the
new show as a playable legendary champion through
their seven-day loyalty program all you have to do
to get the new legendary character is log in once
every seven days between now and July 24th on top
of that players that are brand new to the game
can use my link in the description or scan the
QR code that I put on screen here to get a free
starter pack with a bunch of loot when you use
it the rewards will be in your inbox up here so
be sure to check it out it's actually pretty cool
series recently it was reported that Sam Raimi of
all people is Marvel's pick to direct Secret Wars
as well as Doctor Strange three I'm sure there'll
be a bunch of people in the jokes now that'll say
now Bruce Campbell has to be their version of
the beyonder like he's another kang variant who
just happens to be the beyonder cosmic conquerors
mad Titans and guys with really bad complexions
and that is what we're here to talk about I'm
Bruce Campbell and I'll be your host as we
journey beyond the confines of our own humdrum
reality and see what's really cooking in the
Multiverse the order of some of the Marvel Phase
6 movies has changed a little and they haven't
completely announced which Marvel movies are
coming out between Avengers 5 and Avengers 6
but originally their plan was to have Doctor
Strange 3 be the culmination of the time Runs
Out storyline of the Avengers Comics like the
last movie before Secret Wars in the original
comic storyline the final incursions wind up
happening the beyonders try to destroy the rest
of the Multiverse with Doctor Doom and Doctor
Strange teaming up with the power of molecule
man to stop them from completely erasing reality
in Doctor Doom becomes God Emperor Doom by taking
their power and combining the remnants of all
the universes that are left over into a single
battle world with all the other characters
from The Multiverse that survive so you wind
up with a single Earth for all of reality with
a bunch of Multiverse characters support to this
who was a big help to me against Carnage and
Venom my friend Iron Man there's another team of
superheroes that I've worked with before computer
bring me one of the X-Men which one good question
the MCU version of all these events will be a
little bit different and reportedly this version
of Secret Wars will be more like an amalgam of
the classic 1980s Secret Wars and the more modern
version of Secret Wars but basically the end of
Doctor Strange 3 is the end of the incursions
that's why there was all the incursions talk in
the doctor strange Multiverse with Madness post
credit scene with clea most of reality winds up
getting destroyed in Anthony Mackey's New Avengers
team whoever winds up being on that new roster
or fight the dynasty of Kangs in Avengers 5. I
believe that storyline is meant to borrow a little
from the classic Avengers and Fantastic Four
storylines featuring the Council of Kangs because
there aren't any recent major Avengers story lines
that feature the Council of Kangs but the whole
teaser in the Ant-Man and the Wasp quantumania
post credit scene was the Council of Kangs the
dynasty of Kangs fighting the new Avengers to
stop them from breaching the Multiverse even more
and originally what they were going to do is have
Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 happen in back to back
years like Infinity war and end game so Avengers 5
would have a Downer ending where the new Avengers
are mostly killed by the Council of Kangs sort of
like the same ending as the snap where things
end badly for the new Avengers and because of
everything that's going on with Jonathan Majors
Marvel slowly just kind of wants to move past that
Kang storyline so I believe also part of the idea
is that the beyonder will be played by a different
actor and it'll just be another Kang Baron who
will wind up killing the rest of the Council
of Kangs like who can defeat the Council of Kangs
not the new Avengers but another kang that's even
more powerful played by a completely different
actor in that version of the beyonder winds up
being the one to create battle World pulling all
the characters that survive from the Multiverse
to it and just like Avengers end game Secret
Wars will feature a slightly different roster
of characters like some Will Survive Kang Dynasty
but mostly it'll be different characters and most
of those characters will wind up being the Legacy
Marvel actors from the older Marvel movies pre MCU
like you have your classic Spider-Man movies Toby
Maguire Andrew Garfield that was also one of the
reasons why in Spider-Man no way home they said
we should do this again sometime we should do this
again like I'll hang out it's nice yeah I fought
a an alien made out of black goo once oh no way
I found alien too on Earth for sure yeah it's a
good idea I'll just grab your number at the end
the battle you got it I want to fight an alien
because they were always planning on bringing
those characters back during Secret Wars big
Multiverse crossover that's how they bring back
the Classic X-Men actors the classic Fantastic
Four actors and during Secret Wars Doctor Strange
who has survived Kang Dynasty winds up pulling
together a Multiverse Avengers team of even more
powerful characters using these Legacy actors
in reportedly Kevin feige wanted this version
of Secret Wars to be a big swan song For Those
classic Marvel actors that they never really got
because of all the different buyouts the different
reboots the fox Disney deal that went through
and they'll use that to pay off a lot of the cool
deleted scenes and ideas for crossovers that they
had when all those different Studios controlled
the characters back in the day but they just
couldn't pull off for legal reasons or scheduling
reasons or whatever like Kevin feige doing his
version of the Patton Oswald filibuster movie he
would go find uh hello Spider-Man he would go find
Moon Knight he would go find Daredevil back to the
quinjet and read Church in the Fantastic Four is
piloting it oh it was a fake out before all the
rumors about them splitting Secret Wars into two
parts originally I think they were meant to end
Secret Wars with the Multiverse Avengers beating
that Beyond her character whoever he winds up
being played by and they bring back the Multiverse
with some changes to allow Marvel to explain how
X-Men mutants start popping up all over the place
in the main sixth one sixth Universe in all the
Legacy Marvel actors go back to their universes
like they restore things but with a couple changes
that allow them to make the movies that they want
to make in the future with new actors I think
the history I know is a little different now
because of the extra delays though because of
all the strike stuff that's happening they've
been pushing stuff the last year there have been
a couple rumors that Marvel wants to do a secret
Wars that's so big they have to split it into
two parts mostly they also want that money too
but they really want to have a giant story that's
just way too big for a single movie Avengers end
game almost got to three and a half hours so you
can imagine like they could have almost just gone
a little bit longer and split that movie into
two different parts and if they wind up doing
this Secret Wars part 2 would plan a little
bit more like Avengers forever in the comics
which is like Avengers but across the timeline
with some changes like Avengers from different
points in the timeline showing up to defeat the
beyonder and that's how you bring back characters
that died like Robert Downey Jr returning as
a version of Iron Man he actually went on Joe
Rogan talking about this too like wouldn't it be
cool if you just stepped out of a time machine
boom here's here's what I think they go through
a few semi-lackluster Avengers movies without you
you ready for this I'm red here's a scene there's
a moment where the world's fate is at stake and
they realize they need a Super Genius and then
they figure out how to restart that time machine
great come on man is that the audience sees you
when you when you step out of that thing is this
your and can we you want a little arc on it too
because if this is your idea then you got to
show up for it too I'll do it I'll show up what
do I have to do I don't know I'll do whatever I
have to do we all have to do whatever Kevin but
as part of all this Secret Wars craziness they
pay off all the biggest coolest ideas that they
had long ago either deleted scenes or just ideas
that never wound up make it to the screen that
they couldn't pull off because of legal reasons
or scheduling reasons one of the best examples
is Spider-Man crossing over with Wolverine in
the Classic X-Men and Spider-Man movies let me
know in the comments who do you actually want
to direct that Avengers 6 Movie secret Wars
and what do you want them to do with all the
different Multiverse characters coming back
from the Classic X-Men the classic Spider-Man
Fantastic Four movies one of the great things
about Secret Wars they do wind up doing it as
two parts they could do pretty much every crazy
idea every crazy theory that any fan comes up
with so that's one of the fun things too any
fan theory that you have is probably at least
partially correct at this point that's how
crazy it's going to get during Secret Wars
very much a shut up and take my money situation
congratulations to Kierran Malcolm Tudor and Larry
Miller you're the giveaway winner for my last big
Marvel video please email me on the about page of
my channel so I can get your contact details
by Spider-Man across the spider-verse review
video will post Wednesday after they allow us
to my post-credits scene video full Easter eggs
breakdown videos we'll start posting later this
week after it comes out so be sure to go see it as
soon as possible everyone click here to learn how
Robert Downey Jr almost became Doctor Doom of the
Marvel movies and click here for my new Spider-Man
across the spider-verse trailer video in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!